guess what it's the first before not the
first of Three Brothers three one
whether it's 3-0 no matter it's a reason
it's a seven game series it's the first
to four and we understand that every
game one in this series flips the
pressure to the other team the moment
you win the game the pressure flips to
the other team I don't care if it's game
one I don't care if it's game six only
time the pressure doesn't flip to the
other team is when you win game seven
once game seven is one pressure doesn't
flip to the other team that team goes
home you move on so for us the goal is
to win one game we've been here before
you go win one game all the pressure
flips you go back to crypto three to two
essentially push them in a must win
situation no one wants to go on the road
for game seven and we got nothing to
lose down 3-1 you come on swinging go
down swinging if you do go down but
we're not going down but you leave that
court with no regret and like I said you
win one game series flips pressure flips
everything flips